foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Monarch in British history and with it
came a sense of permanence a state
funeral like no other the culmination of
a period of national mourning that has
witnessed both the end of the second
Elizabethan age and the birth of a new
era for Britain's monarchy
the front line here hasn't moved ever
since the mints agreement was signed
with leader sides making territorial
gains or losses
while this war continues to arouse
condemnation of the Russian invasion on
the world stage here in Ukraine each
death locally seems only to strengthen
the result to join the fight
[Music]
protests and Strikes over the rising
cost of living in France but this one is
by far the largest with workers from
across the public sector
tens of thousands of belgians take to
the streets unable to cope with dramatic
price hikes of course it's not just
holiday presents that have gotten more
expensive it's things like rent and
mortgage rates in response the bank of
England's raised interest rates the
costs of borrowing to their highest in
more than a decade ambulance workers
have joined a long list of public sector
strikes driven to Industrial action
because of low pay in the face of a
crippling cost of living prices
I once again offer a full apology and I
want you to know how sad I am to be
giving up the best job in the world
I am a fighter and not a quitter
that I am resigning as leader of the
conservative party now as he sweeps into
Downing Street for the first time as
prime minister it's time to set out his
agenda I will place economic stability
and confidence
at the heart of this government's agenda
[Music]
Mexico's got one of the highest rates of
journalist murders in the world so it
just seems constant in this chat between
journalists here the tension
and the threat that something could
possibly happen
foreign
enormous galaxies locked in a cosmic
dance this is one of the spectacular
images taken by the web Space Telescope
they designed this experiment so that
the fusion fuel stayed hot enough dense
enough and round enough for long enough
that it ignited take clean energy source
that could revolutionize the world
[Music]
yeah
foreign
[Music]